these performers are Holograms every
series we take one step closer to
achieving all of the sci-fi dreams that
I've ever dreamed of
it's pretty cool you'll never have to
miss a gig again the gig can come to you
we travel to Paris to meet Ian O'Connell
director of the company that put this
show on I recall we were being asked to
produce a show from London to Florida
where the interaction between the
musicians and the audience would be as
natural as two people being in the same
room and for all of us it was an
experience that we'll never forget
so how do they beam this band in live
it's incredible that this really is a
remote live gig the signal from London
takes less than a third of a second to
go all the way around the world and be
projected as a hologram on the stage in
the US as well as the hologram making it
feel like the band are actually in the
room with the audience the band can see
the audience and actually interact and
respond to what they're doing this is a
whole new take on live music but how are
the image is so good that it looks like
the band are really on stage they look
so lifelike because of the angle of the
light and the reflective material called
mylar that creates this holographic
effect the mylar screen is
semi-transparent the reflective surface
reflects the images where the light
falls on it but where the light doesn't
fall on it the audience can see through
it so it looks like there's a person
standing on the stage and that there is
no screen at all the projector receives
the video signal and projects it down
from the ceiling it hits a bounce screen
on the floor which then reflects the
light back up into the mylar which
reflects it at a 45 degree angle into
the audience so if you have something
horizontal on the floor and a reflecting
surface at 45 degrees the final image as
you see here on stage is going to appear
perpendicular what I really love about
this is that if you get the effect of a
3d hologram without
stupid glasses I still believe we've
only scratched the surface with this
technology I think we will see pop-up
Holograms everywhere that's it the
Holograms are here we're officially in
the future